that you sleeping clothes yeah right
right that's it you sleep in clothes I
don't sleep in clothes because my day is
over I'm done with the closed part of my
day it's time to have some fun I can't
get on board with sleeping don't you
feel do you toss and turn yeah of course
okay so then you don't get wrapped up in
your own [__]
no I don't wear a straight jacket but I
also just feel like you're exposing your
privates
and the bed should be like you don't owe
you'll bet anything yeah you or your bed
to be your sanctuary and to be nice and
crisp and neat and clean really cool and
I think I realize why JoJo Rosa gets so
mad at you because you don't really
listen that's crazy you're like putting
clothes on before you go to bed what are
you dumb